- [Instructor] When Quinn
returned from vacation,
he turned the heat back on in his home.
He set the temperature
as high as it could go.
Q represents the
temperature in Quinn's home
in degrees Celsius after t minutes.
This Q is equal to 15 plus 0.4t.
What was the temperature when
Quinn returned from vacation?
So pause this video
and see if you can work
this out on your own.
All right, so they wanna
know the temperature
and you might get a little confused,
hey maybe t is for temperature.
No, t is time in minutes.
Temperature is Q.
Q represents the temperature.
So they really wanna know is,
what was Q when Quinn
returned from vacation?
Well, right when Quinn
returned from vacation,
that is when t is equal to zero.
So this is equivalent to saying,
what is Q, our temperature,
when zero minutes have elapsed?
Well, if you go back to
this original equation,
we see that Q is equal to 15
plus 0.4 times the amount
of elapsed time in minutes.
So that's times zero.
So that's just going to
be 15 degrees Celsius.
If you're familiar with
slope intercept form,
you could think of it as our temperature
is equal to 0.4 times
the elapsed time plus 15.
So t equals zero, you're
left with just this term
which in many cases we
view as our y-intercept.
What is going on right when
we're just getting started?
Right when our horizontal
variable is equal to zero.
And our horizontal variable
in this situation is elapsed time.
How much do the temperature
increase every minute?
There's a couple of ways
you can think about this.
One if you recognize, this
is slope intercept form.
You could see that 0.4 is the slope.
So that says for every one minute
change in time,
you're going to have an
increase in temperature
by 0.4 degrees Celsius.
So you could do it that way.
You could try out some values.
You could say, all
right, let me think about
what Q is going to be based on t.
So time, t equals zero
right when you got home.
We're to figure out
that the temperature
is 15 degrees Celsius.
At t equals one, what happens?
It's going to be 15 plus 0.4 times one.
That's just gonna be 15.4.
Notice, when we increased our time by one,
our temperature increased
by 0.4 degrees Celsius
by the slope.
And what happened again
if we increased time
by another minute, if
we go from one to two,
we would get two, 15.8.
We would increase
temperature by another 0.4.
How much will the temperature increase
if Quinn leaves the
heat on for 20 minutes?
Pause the video and see
if you can solve that.
All right, now we have to be careful here.
They're not asking us
what is the temperature after 20 minutes.
They're saying, how much
will the temperature increase
if he leaves the heat on for 20 minutes?
If we just wanna know
what is the temperature
after 20 minutes, we would just say,
okay, what is Q when t is equal to 20?
So it'd be 15 plus 0.4 times 20.
0.4 times 20 is eight.
Eight plus 15 is 23.
So it's 23 degrees
Celsius after 20 minutes.
But that's not what they're asking us.
They're asking, how much will
the temperature increase?
Well, where did we start from?
We started from 15 degrees Celsius
and now after 20 minutes we
have gone to 23 degrees Celsius.
So we have increased by
eight degrees Celsius.
Or, another way to think about it,
we have increased by this
amount right over here.
We started at 15 and after 20 minutes,
we have increased by 0.4 times 20
which is eight degrees Celsius.
We're done!